midterm elections in the US are just
around the corner and I know what you're
thinking am I too old for Halloween
focus sure midterms aren't the spiciest
but they're important from the minimum
wage to legal marijuana to control of a
little group called the Senate these are
four reasons you should vote every seat
in the house and 36 in the Senate are up
for grabs
if Republicans boot Democrats from six
of their Senate seats and keep control
of the house they'll have full rein over
Congress and if the last four years are
any indication the federal government
has officially shut down 800,000
government employees have been sidelined
the least productive Congress in modern
history there is some good news at least
they're not calling each other names
anymore we're looking at a lot of GOP
concocted legislation and presidential
vetoes but a Republican Congress could
still lead to green lighting the
Keystone XL pipeline which Obama
probably wouldn't block and the
Affordable Care Act getting chipped away
at since the house has already tried to
alter undermine or repeal it 54 times in
the last four years
ah the Supreme Court nine justices who
can decide things like corporations have
First Amendment rights and George W Bush
gets to be President
pretty important well some of the
justices are getting on in years
including two who are considered liberal
and if one of them retires there'd be an
open spot the president gets to nominate
justices but the Senate has to approve
the choice so yeah while Americans can't
directly vote for justices the Senate
could be your only real shot at having a
say forget the country what about where
you live your state your city or even
your block voters in four states will
decide whether to raise the minimum wage
Oregon Alaska and DC will decide whether
to legalize recreational marijuana other
states are weighing in on gun control
prison reform and reproductive rights
and cities will vote on everything from
getting real grass and sports fields to
banning fracking if you don't care about
local elections guess who does the Koch
brothers the billionaire duo is pushing
to get rid of collective bargaining
through their local version of Alec
that's the group that came up with stand
your ground voter ID laws and other
conservative gems
sure u.s. democracy is a far cry from
perfect but if you vote you can even
more justifiably whine later and there
are special interests out they're
banking on people not voting
specifically young folks and people of
color
that's because 70 percent of voters in
the last midterms were white and over 30
the turnout was low for whites under 30
and even lower for young blacks and
Latinos read if you're under 30 nobody
expects you to vote so do it just to
prove them wrong and prove the world
wrong u.s. voter turnout is a bit of an
international laughingstock only 38
percent of the voting age population
showed up at the last midterms that
means the u.s. lags behind France
Kazakhstan and Palau among others Palau
Americans you can do better so those are
four reasons why you should vote in the
midterms are you gonna take the plunge
let us know one more download the aj+
mobile app and join the conversation
available in your App Store now